I am very impressed by I feel like you
were running your life almost from a
very early age right and this is this
kind of made you would you say that
that's what made me the fact that you
had to be so self-reliant so early don't
you think that that had something to do
with yeah I often uh worry about my uh
you know I have uh such good friends
that they're all such terrific parents
and uh and I worry about the kids you
know what I mean because
I you know having alcoholic up
suicidal mental patient parents right is
really really helpful for uh character
development um and uh yeah you your eyes
are wide open to the the full uh scope
of The Human Condition at an early age
so you have a a high emotional
IQ um I used to think it me I should
like join the CIA or something but later
in therapy discovered it was actually
just in hyper vigilance of constantly
being you know terrified and assessing
situations so it's not really that I was
uh reading the room so well and could U
retain clues or random pieces of
information it's just um clocking things
you kind of have to to survive yeah and
yes by like I think like by six probably
uh yes at our friend uh we saw each
other at pe's Memorial at Paul Ruben's
Memorial yeah
and uh I think I
did
Playhouse when you were a you were a
child actor and you did's Playhouse yeah
yeah and so I guess and I love love Paul
MH uh but he was like I remember he was
one of the first guys uh that you know
he took me to a steak dinner I talked
about this at the
memorial and uh um when I got out a a
rehab he was one of the first people
that was like oh hey let me take you out
to dinner and it meant so much to me
yeah um we had stakes in the valley
someplace and I was like wow I'm really
back and uh and I guess he had been
through so much mhm that uh he sort of I
think you know uh Susan Terrell from Fat
City they used to say that about her
that she would also sort of like collect
underdogs you know what I mean like and
hold them tight there's some people in
this town that are really like that and
it's a very special thing um cuz most
people are just like well how do not
want to be Associated proxy or I don't
and Paul said to me uh oh I was never
surprised when I saw all those like
pictures of you in the gutter or
whatever you got to remember I I Met
Your
Mother and it was pretty wild because
she stage mom then very much uh less of
a stage mom more of like a stage nut job
and uh
so I think uh I honestly I don't I
don't have a mind that can recall
sufficient force uh what it was like um
exactly but and they're not bad people
my parents you know it's like they're
just uh very untreated uh like in other
words so many things in our modern times
um whatever this year is um um I'll say
2024 I uh you know discussions happen
about sort of uh mental health and kind
of whatever you know uh epigenetic
footprint what have you like people
understand that that's a working part of
a dynamic of being a person a a high
functioning person or recovery or
whatever it takes and so I sort of well
only because they're dead um now I kind
of love them you know what I mean I
think we have distance too I mean that's
the ultimate distance actually oh yeah
it was such a relief when they died uh I
uh like it's funny that uh people don't
really tether the two but it's like as
soon as they died I was like okay now
I'll do show businesses so it's really
only in like the last decade uh up to
then I was mostly trying to avoid it
because I I didn't want these kind of
like lindsy Lohan figured parents in my
life on page six you know so I was like
I'll just stay here in the shadows until
they die and kind of work a little bit
here and there do you really think you
did that because you've worked a lot
you're starting with Orange is the New
Black and you're doing Russian
doll poker face poker face and it's just
like there you've had this unprecedented
run of
creativity do you really think that that
was made possible because your parents
I I I think it's empirical um I just
yeah it was a very you know it's like
PTSD um which is uh my my only uh
diagnosis and a shocking twist because
you'd think I was insane in so many
other confirmed ways um which I believe
I am I just can't get a
diagnosis uh I think they're wrong but
uh you know
and you don't really take medication I
guess you do I whatever anyway um but
yeah like for me I would I experienced
them as as boogey men you know what I
mean and like in my Waking Life and in
my night terror life like because they
were insane you know um and so I
had to get like a restraining order from
my dad or whatever um I remember being
really brokenhearted uh how old were you
when you got a restraining order from
your dad I well I was older already
because like when I was younger it was
harder I had tried like he would show up
at things like uh I remember beu
Phillips in the 9s told me like yeah
your dad came to set today and it was
like a remember that weird James James
Brooks move no what's his name uh Jim
toek anyway with Mike Tyson in it um is
something black and white do you
remember this movie I vely do
remember this from the 90s I've never
seen it um could you uh Google that
thank he's also making you an Airline
reservation oh thank you so so much
really really important uh and maybe
it's called black and white or something
said James took well well you you you
struggle with that a while and I I'll
stay here you're just giving him tasks
to keep him busy yeah I just like to
stay I just like to stay where is
Uranium on the uh on the elemental chart
yeah and uh so uh well anyway she told
me uh oh your dad showed up to set today
looking for you he just assumed since it
was a shooting in New York City and Mike
Tyson was in the movie that you were in
it too it's called black and white oh it
is uh thanks and uh then but there was
nothing I could do about that kind of
thing then um but years later I guess I
was uh probably 30 or something uh which
is weird because I'm 27 now
someone you there was a singularity and
then there was a hole in space yeah and
so
don't if you see something say something
yeah definitely yeah hey and give a hoot
don't
pollute well anyway but it's important
these are the truths a lot of truths are
coming out here and like don't Google it
okay all right whatever you do um I like
the idea of this you're just starting to
vigorously uh lie about my age and it's
definitely on
Google and but so anyway then later I
was doing this play it was like a a Mike
Lee play and I remember I I was so
excited um and uh you know Mike Lee was
there and then I remember seeing my dad
from across the room like somehow he had
found um he had done that also with uh
slums of Beverly Hills like I remember
cuz you were you were a kid when you did
that yeah I guess I was like 17 18 yeah
and but I remember he like showed up to
the premiere but hadn't seen him in like
uh a decade or something and he was and
he just showed up yeah and he was like
Hey bambo and you know my dad was a
boxing promoter um and uh from from
Brooklyn uh which is why I never
understand why people want to move there
um like no the goal is to get out of
Brooklyn uh but you know they think it's
hip it changed a lot well uh did it you
know what I mean I'd argue it's still
not in Manhattan
uh so on as a baseline you know
geographically speaking has it changed
oh I see they got some coffee shops
congratulations oh but you still
right so like you mean I can't I the one
joy in New York is you can come
and go as you please there's like
there's no claustrophobia or commitment
uh Brooklyn is is a commitment
like you need a an Uber a Subway a met
show cart a taxi or a very long walk so
anyway then I remember him being uh
seeing him across from the mik Le and
just broke I broke my heart slums
Beverly Hills um I remember Rosie per
Rosie Perez and Marissa to kind of like
consoling me in the bathroom it was like
three of the thickest accents you'd ever
heard and they just like yo Natasha like
you don't need this don't
let him bring you down like you
you don't got to go through this like
you know like just do whatever
you got to do but this is your night
it's your night you know and
don't let that haunt you
and um so he was up like that and
my mother was just uh nuts nuts but they
weren't really like bad people and
anyway now that they're dead I
feel safe to kind of really be out there
and um I don't care anymore you know
it's funny cuz you had all this success
early on then you just
decided uh cuz clearly they said to you
at some point all right so what do you
want to do now I was reading some
interview with you we said like I don't
want to be on Dawson's Creek I don't
want to do I don't want to be on the WB
that's not what I want um which I think
you know 99% of people in that situation
would have said how do I get on that
kind of reality and that's not what you
wanted no and uh yeah I did not want
those things like and and I remember my
mother being like like why would you
turn down by Cofe it's such a Big Show
and like when are you going to get a
boob job so you can work and I was like
H yeah I'm just not putting that in
my tits ma like I am not she was like it
would even you out cuz you got that ass
I was like well thanks
and my God but like I think that this is
the talk I never had with my parents
this is the b in the Beast talk no
that's what they told
me